the fact that i graduated during a
global pandemic is something that will
never cease to amaze me and i think i
can speak for all 2020 graduates when i
say that it has been a very interesting
journey so far today i can proudly say
that i was able to get my first job at a
very reputed company and i have simply
learned to thank for their support in
upscaling my journey
hi my name
i is very unsure of what to do next
all my friends were either starting
their master or had already landed in
the first house then a relative of mine
suggested that i should
simply learn and gave me the confidence
that doing so will lead to better career
prospects for me in the future i started
to explore the central platform a little
and saw that they offered a data
scientist masters
on the first day of the course i learned
that the instructor was someone who was
working with amazon and i remember being
very impressed since he was a seasoned
professional in his field he was able to
teach us using real-world examples that
really helped me better my understanding
i think the course in general is
designed very well but i particularly
enjoyed the machine learning and data
science with python process i believe
that they helped me fulfill my aim of
upstate i am also a cricket enthusiast
just like in sports i think even while
upskilling discipline is very important
waking up early and planning my day in
advance is a habit that i developed
because of the course
i think the main takeaway from my
journey so far is that it is important
to continue working towards your goal
even if you feel like you are stuck in a
rut things will start looking up if you
keep working hard so keep to your
commitment to reach your goal work hard
and you will find success
[Music]